one of the top guys in the league at
percentage yield drives it ultra the
shoot that three
peel along the sideline give it go
there's a good problem to have
yeah you got a lot of guys up front
Lamar the rotations the person live
watches the games and lets him know
after the game in quilt upbeat Wizards
on the attack me as it takes for a
little hesitant any help
so therefore everybody should be a
tatsuta man the box outlet Turner's
chases him off the treatment pool right
now are the Wizards that get into the
half-court set in just 12 attempts from
three-point range
be off the screen Turner horses him down
and fight Frazier racehorse dribble into
the lane finds bill sets his feet Bailey
on five feel has been tonight he steps
back he'll launch it head other that day
have not had much scoring from anyone
other than this man right here lead has
been 23 this went back in the first half
13
in progress Beals bohemian Scotland with
it reset to the shack pocket on appeal a
trip of God good three-point shooter
this time has often to turn it to you
know why would you bill
straight Armand Connaughton trying to
keep it in a fake comes off the screen
Colin switches out not be a little fire
the triple God right
forty nine point and the Blazers have it
taken away a bright lines feel for the
two-hand Jam so bill still has an up
spring and those legs after forty three
minutes and 51 points to get up and
packing and the Wizards are going to win
this one and I